how often do you think about your own
mortality every day
and
one are you afraid
of it the uncertainty of it and what do
you think happens after you die sure i'm
afraid of it i mean because it's uh i
don't i don't
know
what's next i mean i i can't know what
the way i know you so of course i'm
afraid of it and i think of it every day
that's true
my prayer life uh compels me you know we
have this the um
the hail mary prayer you know you pray
the rosary uh now and at the hour of our
death amen now and at the hour of our
death amen
now at the hour of our death amen you
prayed the whole rosary if there's 50
times
you remind yourself of your own death
but i do i think about it
because it's the ultimate limit it's why
it's it's beguiled every artist and
writer and philosopher it's the ultimate
limit you know question
but yeah sure i'm afraid of it because
it's the unknown uh
what do i think happens
i think i'm drawn into the
deeper embrace of god's love
you know and that's stating it kind of
in a in a more poetic way um
do you know john polkinghorn's work do
you know that name
john paul camera was a very interesting
just died recently
he was a cambridge university particle
physicist right high high level
scientist
who at midlife
became an anglican priest he left his
job at cambridge and went to the
seminary became an anglican priest right
and then wrote i think some of the best
stuff on science and religion because he
really knew the science from the inside
here's pulkinghorn's account that i've
always found
persuasive he said
what what survives after we die so this
body clearly dies and goes into the
ground or it's burned up or it goes away
right but what's preserved and he says
what aristotle would have called the
form pokemon calls it the pattern so the
the pattern that's organized
the the matter that's made me up over
all these years that's obviously not the
same as it was
even i mean you would know how often it
all changed all your atoms and cells and
you know
there was a the the little you know
bobby baron who was growing up in
birmingham michigan there i could have a
picture of him and then there's me and i
said oh this is the same person well i
mean clearly not materially speaking not
at all completely different
but there's there's a unity to whatever
that pattern is by which
all of that materiality's been kind of
organized you know so paul karen says
i think that pattern is remembered
by god
and remembers the wrong word as though
it's like derivative i mean it's known
by god
and so god can therefore
re-embody me according to that pattern
at a higher pitch what we call the
resurrected body
uh
so paul talks about a spiritual body
his body for sure because he believes in
the resurrection of jesus
um
but it's not a body like ours from this
world it's a it's a body at a higher
pitch
so something
some pattern that's there persists
pattern
persists in the mind of god and then is
used as the ground of the re-embodiment
of me so it's not like i've just become
a platonic form
i'm going to be re-embodied because the
christian hope is not for
platonic escape of soul from matter
that's never the christian hope it's for
the resurrection of the body we say
and he said what a fantastic idea
well i don't know
i mean this body is being reconstituted
all the time according to this pattern
right it's not the same matter and so
might there be an another sort of higher
material that is
organized according to the same pattern
which has been remembered by god so
therefore we can hang on to the language
of body and soul if you want or matter
and form
but it's
the form remembered by god and then
it in an embodied way by god that we
call
heaven the heavenly state
that's what i hope for that's my
christian faith my christian hope
let me ask you about the big question of
of meaning
we've talked about in different
directions
from different perspectives what's the
meaning of our existence here on earth
what's the the meaning of life
love
god is love
and the purpose of my life is to become
god's friend
and that means i'm more conformed to
love and so my life finds meaning in the
measure that i become
more on fire with the divine love
i'm like the burning bush is to become
more and more radiant with the presence
of god
that's what gives life meaning
meaning is to live in a purpose of
relationship to a value i would say so
there's all kinds of values as i say
moral aesthetic intellectual values and
when i have a purposive relationship so
right now you and i we have a purposive
relationship to the value of let's say
you know finding out the truth of things
and we're speaking together to seek that
well good
what's the ultimate value the value of
values is god the supreme good right the
supremely knowable the supremely
intelligible is god
and so to be conformed to god is to have
a fully meaningful life and who's god
god is love so that's why i would fit
the package together that way
you're
adding a lot of love to this world and
which is something i deeply appreciate
and that you would sit down with me
uh given how valuable your time is is a
huge honor thank you so much my great
pleasure i loved it lex thank you
you